um
yo one of the the dope things that uh
you did recently
was this mike tyson interview which was
like last year because that was kind of
like when you were in la doing the
run with mo three but they held on to it
for a while three albums
yeah so they they held onto that for a
minute cause i remember hearing about it
and uh and i was like yeah when's this
[ __ ] gonna come out but that was an
interesting uh interview
how did you take mike's intensity
because it was very
i mean it was it was up there uh
i ain't really taking like nothing bro
like i was just
i was just you know i was just i was
just in there you know
and we had a lot of stuff we talked
about off camera like bro
the character he's a wild boy dude
yeah i mean i i thought i i thought that
was like
because you're you're you're a
personality he's a personality yeah
i was really running it i was asking him
like man how you know when people scared
of you when they walk in the ring
and he was like you been to penitentiary
you know how when you walk in there and
you know who you going [ __ ] ass who's
the [ __ ]
i'm like [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] we going with this
he said that yeah i'm like man tyson how
you know [ __ ] could be scared
of you when they walk in the ring
and he said like you've been the
penitentiary
you know who's a [ __ ] when they walk in
right how they look you know who's the
[ __ ] who's gonna get
[ __ ] i'm like what the [ __ ]
i'm like this [ __ ] tyson boy
this [ __ ] crazy bro